so in case you miss it the myth
the big yellow bright sign this is the
hitchhiker's guide to uxing without a
uxer
and um in case any of you don't know
this is me and me so my name is chrissy
welsh and i'm the lead ux for
a company called back bass and we handle
like um
basically the front end for like a
financial institutions like abn amro and
stuff but
precursor to that i'm also one of the
cloud nine ide alumni so it was their
ux over there as well before i started
there
and my background is in
working with development teams to really
try and build great stuff
and this is what i wanted to talk about
which is
sort of like the big elephant in the
room as i like to think about it
i'm going to check my remote yay
i'm in control okay
so this is a big elephant in the room
and this is it here right
and this is what i hear over and over
and over again i want to build
great things i start with really great
intentions
but always turns out rubbish what
happens
and this is a story i hear and it's so
so
prevalent and all the different teams i
work in
and this is how it happens is that you
start at point a
and you want to build the best app you
want to build the best product
in your little startup team and you need
to get to point b
and you think this is the way to do it
as
quickly and as fast as possible that's
not necessarily the best thing
because your great experiences and your
happy users and your easy interfaces
kind of live outside of that fast
approach
so if you want to build great things you
kind of have to live a little bit
outside of
the fast approach to getting things done
and getting things done kind of looks
like a big wavy line like this
if you want to do it really really well
but i don't want you to panic about it i
don't want you to worry that you can
still get things done you can still do
it in the right way without having to
take the fast road all the time and this
is really what i want to talk to you
just now so i have about 20 minutes so
you've got to kind of
keep your hat on because we're going to
be going really fast is that
i want to take you through how important
it is to have a vision and you just need
the one you don't need many just have
one vision i want to see how
you help you think like a user
help you help your users
why you should wireframe at all and how
to do it
how to make something throw away like a
prototype
that allows you to test some of your
hypotheses allows you to test whether
your idea is even good at
all how to evaluate that and
lastly when you should scrap it if you
need to scrap it
because ooh
slow sync because a journey of a
thousand miles always starts with one
step and for those of you who like
journey and have a ps2
this slide's for you no one awesome
one person at the back i like you okay
okay
that's not good
yay okay so the vision
do you have one for your product if you
don't have one
i would ask why not so whenever you
started out with um an idea of what you
want to make
you tended to think a lot about what it
should do and what it should be
and it's very important to keep that in
mind because if you take
a set aside and you take a step away
from it
you what you get is feature creep and
you get lots of things being added in
that don't necessarily adhere to what
was going to be the great thing in the
first place
queen had a vision one
was a very nice record for those queen
fans anyone a queen fan
excellent
so this is what i want you to do and
this will keep you honest when it comes
to your vision
i want you to print this out and i want
you to put it on your wall whenever
you're going into your development
environment
what one thing do you want your product
your service
your offering to do well just one
you can have okay i'll let you have one
or two but it should really do one thing
really really well i should do one thing
awesome and you should know what that is
and it should be visible to everyone
i have mine for my entire team to see in
the wall every single day and it's a2
so it's not like a4 like second off it's
really massive
and it makes sure that whenever we do
something it always
we reference this back all the time
because it should be simple until you
make it complicated the thing that
you're building the startup you have
it should start simple because it's very
easy to add complications in
it's very difficult to keep things
simple
so starting with the user
do you know who your users are when you
start with your products when you start
with your service do you know who they
are
do you know what they're doing do you
know what they're trying to do do you
know why they're doing it
and if you want to be good at ux and you
want to do this with a uxr this is
one of the top tips i can give you and
that is really think
about who your users are write out who
will be using your application or your
website
write out their age their education and
then finally i want you to name that
person
in this case we've got arthur dent here
for those that like
douglas adams yay woohoo
bunny slippers coats funny t-shirt
anyway this is uh who the user is
and when you do this they become real so
whenever you think
what would arthur do in this situation
would he want
this would he want this feature if
you're adding something new in
so why crazy lady are you making me name
imaginary people
that's the second thing i get a lot from
developers why
am i creating imaginary people out of
nowhere and why are you making me do
this
because i want you to do this i want you
to fight for your users
and i'm mixing metaphors but your users
are what's going to make you
popular they're going to make you
successful
they're going to use your application
they're going to use your products
they're the ones who are going to make
it
awesome for you in your job and they're
going to they're the ones that keep you
in your job they're probably the ones
with the paid subscriptions
you've got to fight for them and less of
the business needs
more for the user
so this is how simple your user persona
and we call them personas in the ux
industry but i won't bog you down too
much with
this kind of technical details but this
is um arthur's less attractive older
brother called james
this is james then 32.
i've written down some key goals for
what he is he knows what he wants to buy
his behaviors he gets bored very quickly
so don't serve them fluffy
product descriptions and don't overwhelm
them too much with choice because you're
going to lose them so this is basically
if you have a website or service
and this is just a very simple example
of how a person or how a user that you
can reference can be it can be this
simple
okay i'm going to stand next to my
computer because my remote just lost
connection
so what does it look like in real life
well it can look like this
this is a bit more complicated but
there's no the point i'm trying to
illustrate is there's really no right or
wrong way to do personal work
it can be a couple of different ways
or is this right whatever makes sense to
you whatever you understand the best
a couple of these have some benefits
over others but it really depends on
how you understand your users and how
you want to use how you want to do it
next thing i want you to do is start to
wireframe so before you touch
a single piece of code with your awesome
idea and your one vision and you know
who's going to use it i want you to
get hit the pen and paper if you can do
this
you can really get to grips with what
you should be building
and wireframes are not about pretty
pictures they're about getting
the functionality right about what
should be in there
and why on earth would you do that well
there's a couple of key benefits to
wireframing i can tell you
really really fast to lay things out
super fast imagine a wall of just
a4 sheets you can pull that together in
30 minutes 40 minutes
you can iterate on that an even faster
amount of time
it's super super easy to see everything
that you have
and you can iterate on it you can pull
sheets down redraw it put it back up
again
you can have this whole process doesn't
have to be long and it doesn't have to
be involved
but it will help you get things right
and it'll help you get them right before
you waste time and money and code
because it's cheaper than changing code
changing pieces of paper so much cheaper
than changing code paying for a
developer to have to redo things
if you can hit it on the paper then
it'll save you a lot of time and effort
so again this is about ideas and this is
about iteration
and i was kind of trying to illustrate a
point which is
having one idea super great i'm glad you
have one
and like right behind you in your corner
clapping
iteration in one idea even better you've
taken that one idea and you've taken it
a couple of steps further and you've
made it
you've made it you've taken it to the
pinnacle of what it can be
but you get a couple of ideas going you
iterate on them
and you can get something that is just
super cool
ready for the vision that you had in
mind in the first place
you iterate on something and you go over
a few times and you build it
you can have something which is
exponentially better than the
very first idea you had never ever hit
code if i can give you a tiny piece of
advice with
the first idea you get let percolate
and go over a few things first
so what do wireframes look like well i
thought i would share one of mine
and the point i'm trying to make is
they're not pretty
and they're not there to be pretty
they're there to be functional
and um for any user have used cloud9 id
in the past this was one of the um
dialog boxes i had done for cloud9
and it's a complicated piece of a dialog
box with lots of um
bits that you can't read in my scribbly
handwriting
but trust me it's all golden
and what does it turn into well with a
visual designer it can turn into
something like this before a programmer
works on it
but it just means that whenever you
start work you've got it right the first
time can you imagine having to iterate
on this
three four or five times before you get
it right
the developer would be shooting me in
the back if i turned my back on him for
too long
but what if you really hate paper you're
allergic to it you absolutely can't
stand it
or you had a really bad experience in
art class and you never want to touch a
piece of paper again
well don't panic you can use software
too
there's software like balsamiq fn who
knows balsamic
oh you're damn awesome i love you
who likes it less people
okay right so this is balsamic
and it allows you to do some very fast
iterations on um
sort of layouts and designs you can
throw things into there and you can
export it as pdf or png
and that allows you to do multiple
things print them out put them on the
wall
use them as prototyping link screens
together there's a whole heap of things
you can do with it
and this one again it's a cloud9 example
and it was um
doing a flow diagram for how you can
actually get through
from one screen to the next and what you
actually have to show at each stage
and there's lots of little virtual
sticky notes
because i like sticky notes
so some wireframing tools that you can
use so you're not limited to pen and
paper or balsamic there's actually a
whole heap of things it depends what
you're comfortable in i guess
and there's no hard and fast rules as
long as you do it at some point
and that is pen and paper would be my
number one
because it's super fast and super cheap
and if you're allergic
to pen and paper you can use balsamic
and if you really hate balsamic you can
go back to pen and paper as
most of the room seems to do um there's
like sure as well but that's super
expensive it's like six thousand
euros or something like that first year
so unless you're a corporate company i
would avoid that one
and then there's your usual photoshop
illustrator
so i'll tell you if you're going to show
wires to a client or wireframe to a
client
never ever ever show them paper never
ever they will not understand it
i have two stories for that i showed the
client some paper i spent a whole week
doing these
really great mock-ups and i was thinking
they'll get it they'll understand that
it's
the idea is golden and it's solid they
looked at paper and went why are you
writing on paper i don't understand what
we paying you for
conceptually they don't really
understand it so if you're going to show
a client something
try to go as high fidelity as possible
and by high fidelity i mean like as
visual as you can with it
but i also have a story about that i
showed a client once
really high fidelity wireframes because
of that first experience
and i went i'm not going through that
again so i went and showed some really
awesome photoshop like
wireframes and these things were cool
and you know what happened they liked
the wireframe so much it ended up being
how it would look
so the wireframes in green white i kid
you not was what they wanted to produce
at the end because it was so high
fidelity so
i would take the middle roads not one or
the other or you're in dangerous
territory at the other end
and envision app who knows envision app
a couple of people started render back
if you don't know it
it's really great you can link flat
screens like pngs
or jpegs or whatever you want it's
really super cool
and you can create like little
prototypes for yourself
and you can share those with people so
you can link those bad boys up
and that's going to be good so what does
a prototype look like
well you know how i made you do all
those wireframes earlier and you've got
all these bits of paper
well guess what you can do with them you
can make prototypes with them
and you can actually shuffle those bits
of paper around ask people to click on
them
ask for feedback say do you know where
you're going give them a task to do
give them the paper and you move the
paper around and see if they do a task
now if you're wondering how that what
that looks like
it looks like this so you have little
pieces of paper
they can be drawings they don't have to
be printouts just in case you're
wondering
and you just shuffle them around and you
ask people to use your finger as a mouse
and you can click on things and this is
a really nice easy fast
cheap way especially if you're a
bootstrap company very cheap to do this
and
this is kind of people working their way
through their wireframes and you can see
some confused faces
you will see that a lot if you do this
but you will also catch a lot of your
problems and your functionality by doing
this very small step and actually
showing something earlier
there's a great um quote i said i heard
and that was
if you're uncomfortable showing your
work you're at the right stage to show
it
so if you're uncomfortable showing it
that's the point where you should be
doing it because you'll catch all the
the bugs and things earlier in your own
designs
and this is envision apps this is what i
was telling you about so if you want to
link those screens and you have flat
screens already
great tool to do it creates little
hotspots you can click on things link
them together
works really well works really cool and
if anyone wants to see these things i
have live examples so i can
take you over to the hallway
out there and i can show you stuff as
well if you really if you're really
curious about it
so so far i've made you print a vision
on a wall
which you're all very happy you've got
your one vision just like queen
you've got um you know who your users
are
and you can reference them you've got
some wireframes that you've turned into
a clickable prototype
now what you're going to do well i want
you to evaluate your own work
i want you to put the shoes on of that
james then arthur's less attractive
older brother
and i want you to think like him
whenever you look at your work it
doesn't have to be a back
i'm just trying to make a point um
and when you think about them i want you
to really see if you can be that person
be that user and evaluate your work
it's great to get other people in or
segment groups but that's costly
and this whole talk is about bootstrap
startups and how to get started quickly
so put on the shoes of the user evaluate
your work
other ways you can do to gather data
there's a great tool it's called
usability hub
it's a karma based system so you
evaluate other people's work they
evaluate yours and you get
really really awesome feedback and it
helps
and this is not a very involved process
but it is testing and it's good testing
and um again you can use these kind of
flows and diagrams and a b
splits to actually get some really cool
stuff going
so this is why
we're doing all this right it's because
greatness and
real true greatness does not take
shortcuts
and it's true it doesn't there's no
quick way to a to b
but i can get the process down a lot
shorter and smaller so that
you can get to greatness a lot faster
but it does require a bit of work and a
bit of thinking
so what if you can't evaluate that work
fairly yourself well if you can't you
don't can't conceptualize and you
just can't evaluate what you're trying
to do you look at it and it looks okay
to you but
you get the feeling it's maybe not so
what happens if you can't do it
by yourself you need to find a friend
maybe not these friends i don't think
courtney cox is going to value your
application for you
but if you have a friend bring them in
try not to tell them
anything about what you're doing and get
them to sit down and use what you're
building
if you're uncomfortable showing what
you've got you're probably doing it
right
because you're getting that feedback
early
and this is somewhat what it looks like
so
you've got to sit the back and send
nothing and they're going to
sit at the front and they're going to do
a couple of tasks that you set them
or they're going to talk to you about
what they think about what they're
saying
and then you get to write down or you
get to say nothing but just take notes
and the best advice i can give you
is to say and do nothing and try to give
nothing away because a user will try to
please you
so someone that you get and even your
friend will try to do it right
and that's um that can be dangerous
because if you're
they'll want to make sure that your
product is good but what you really want
is fair feedback
so the list the less you say at this
point the best the better
so what really happens when it doesn't
go as expected so you've done all this
hard
work right and you've got the evaluation
back
and actually the evaluation gave you
something like this
probably because you didn't stay true to
your one vision you've
had one two three four visions in there
or something
and you've got a bit of a frankenstein's
monster of a product or service that
does
nothing really very well well at this
point
you really need to think about your own
work right
so you need to think about this are you
going to keep it or are you going to bin
it
and this is when i was trying to tell
you about earlier is that
it's a process and if it's a fast
process then you can
get to this point a lot faster is that
there's no point in spending six months
your life developing something that
isn't great
or isn't going to be great and it's much
better for you if you've been out early
than it is if you keep going
so please don't get too attached to your
projects they can sometimes feel like
your little baby that you have you're a
golden child that's going to become
the next jesus but
um it's probably better that you are
able to evaluate your work
and see if it is good because the next
great idea could be just around the
corner for you as well
so is this everything i have to tell you
about user experience
no no there's a whole lot more to it
than this
but if we're talking about getting the
basics right and we're talking about
building something really really super
awesome then
this is going to help you get started
really quickly and really well
it's going to get you to the point where
you could probably hire a professional
in to do this for you
and that if i can make any
recommendations to someone is that they
don't do it themselves so you actually
get a professional in
but if you do if you have to then please
do these steps
so here's what we just covered in a very
fast lightning style fashion
which is um how important it is to have
one of your visions and print it on your
wall and make it visible so that
everything you do you reference back to
that
how you can think like a user which is
take those steps to write down who they
are name them please
reference them whenever you think about
your features
i want you to think about wireframing i
want you to think about getting the
functionality of what you're trying to
do right make sure all the steps are in
place
if you need to think about the edge
cases please do but make it work for the
80
of your users first and then the last 20
you can make work with the edge cases
how to make a throwaway prototype which
is
use those wireframes use those papers
reuse them and actually
make a finger clickable prototype that
you can use
how to evaluate your own work which is
um take a step back and really think
about your user and
if it fits their needs and finally when
you need to scrap it which is after the
evaluation process
if it didn't go well you need to really
think about whether you should carry on
so so long and thanks for all the fish i
will be taking questions so
i think i did that in super fast time so
i'm free for some questions
or not yeah okay couple of minutes
anyone have any questions about all that
lightning fast speeds there's a hand
behind the
cameraman han you can go
yes
okay so what you're saying to me is that
whenever someone
you're saying that clients need to see
something
of a high fidelity or client need to see
low fidelity
because then they understand that it's
going to take longer to build
experiences
see that that seemed like a workaround
for a different problem
that's someone showing low fidelity
because they can't explain to the client
how long it's going to take to actually
build so that sounds more like a
communication problem
than what you should actually do with
your user experience
but when it comes to low fidelity the
benefits of it are that it's throw away
and it's fast
high fidelity takes longer to do so
whenever you do things at a higher level
of design it's ready to be built it's
ready to pass to a developer
but you should be getting that feedback
much earlier on if you're talking about
clients then
you should be getting the feedback for
what you're building
um at a high a medium to high fidelity
stage if you show something to finish
like i was saying in my early example
they actually think that's what they're
going to get because the design hadn't
touched it yet
that's sometimes what you end up
building but my advice would always be
and what i just stated which is use the
low fidelity internally
use it for yourselves it's not for shows
to other people
when you get to a medium or you're
iterating on that to look a little
better
and it can look a little better in like
balsamic or any kind of digital tools
low fidelity i consider to be paper
medium i consider to be balsamic or um
like lines and boxes in illustrator and
when it comes to high fidelity
i consider that to be almost finished
designs in photoshop so i would take the
middle part
and i would show that to clients that
would be my advice
hi chris how are you guys [ __ ] what are
you in your experience the signals that
tell you
whether a ux design from a developer
perspective there are other signals
but from a ux designer design is a
throwaway or
it can be improved like what what what
what are the markers you
if every single user turned round to you
and says i don't understand what i'm
doing
i don't understand what this serves or
what purpose this is then that would be
a surefire sign that you need to stop
what you're doing because no one is
getting it
no one's getting the idea or the vision
but if people are saying
oh i see it now i can get it comes down
to the feedback
it comes down to interpretation of the
feedback that you get
so if you get some positive parts inside
the feedback
then you can carry on but if everything
you're getting comes back
negative that would be the point where i
would say this
is not really going to work or they
don't get what i'm trying to do so maybe
what you've done
doesn't doesn't go to the vision of what
you were trying to create
thank you you're welcome
questions yeah
so would it be philly at the end when
you finally get around to making like an
actual prototype because like i followed
this model before and i find it quite
waterfall
like it gets to the stage of the build
and by the time you get to end of the
build
everything's had to change because of
various things of this and i i tend to
find
when you get to stage where you're
making like a clickable prototype
these days most people can make it just
as fast as something like bootstrap and
make something that's actually real
well most people i've worked with in ux
will find that a lot better to do it
that way
yeah it actually makes something real so
people can use a computer
click around as opposed to just
imagining what it might be like
yeah i'm with you there if you're
actually much more versatile you have a
dedicated ux professional that is the
way to go
if you don't have that then i would much
recommend you don't have to do clickable
prototypes you can do them on paper
before you start the development cycle
if you don't have someone like me and
your team
but i work in agile teams so it's it's
not this waterfall way it is an
iterative process and you do go through
in fact i've worked in lean teams before
where you're on your own even
but um the answer to your question is if
you have a dedicated ux person
then what you're describing is
absolutely 100 to if you don't have a
dedicated person which is
what this talk is for then these steps
will help you keep things
honest keep things good also you can use
top coat
instead of bootstrap you can use lots of
things
you can listen to lots of frameworks
we're not exclusive
um i i've got a question so i'm just
gonna selfishly jump in
um how do you feel uh mobile impacts
this do you guys do
like mock up some wireframes for like
all the possible screen sizes when
you're
when you're building stuff out um the
answer is i generally do
um depends on what you're building if it
is cross device
if it's mobile tablet desktop then yes
of course you have to
factor that in and there's actually
really cool things if you're working in
paper their post-its
have now got the mobile size because
they understand that people use them now
whenever they're wireframing so you can
even get post-its in tablet and mobile
now
and you can just draw them on and
they're the right size for you to work
on
so you don't even need to like work out
what the sizes are anymore
so the answer is yes and there is lots
of strategies
and for ux to work on which is mobile
first which is a popular one
but um i would generally work if it's
cross device yes of course
um i was working what the core
functionality would be and put that in
the smaller devices first
but you've got device appropriateness as
well which is some things are not
appropriate per device
so for example if you're doing i'll just
give you a recent one loan application
forms
not appropriate for mobile however
information on loan application forms
are more appropriate tablet and desktop
so it's sometimes you have to not
always go well this is essential for
mobile but what's appropriate per device
as well and that factors into the ux
process too
so i don't know if that answers your
question or not totally okay cool
uh more questions oh yeah
last last question i think last question
and i'll be out in the hallway for any
more questions
if you want me to look at anything i'm
here to help you so
if you need any advice so you're talking
about
the user personas and breaking that down
and really
digging into who your user base is um do
you have anything to say about
when you're seeking feedback how best to
or
if it makes sense to go after specific
representatives from the that user base
yeah there is a more involved process
where you can go after the segments
that you've described you can go after
that 30 year old value hunter for
example or something that you really
want to go for and you have to make your
own judgment as to how
you categorize those people so yes of
course you will get better results if
you do that
but it's better to get any feedback than
none
so it's better to just get some feedback
than no feedback
no feedback is the death of whatever
you're doing but some feedback will help
you
and even better than that is exactly
what you described which is targeted
feedback
but that takes a long more involved
process and again if you don't have
a dedicated ux professional then any
feedback's better than none
awesome thank you chrissy you're very
welcome
you